operieren üben an Bananen sie haben in
der Ukraine Medizin studiert flohen nach
Deutschland doch sie gelten nicht als
Kriegsflüchtlinge und müssten eigentlich
zurück in ihre Heimatländer
Afrika verlassen um ein guter Arzt zu
werden ich möchte in Deutschland bleiben
und hier weiter studieren wir brauchen
die Leute hier ja wir brauchen sie ist
Ecken und Enden mehr als 2000
Studierende aus der Ukraine sind in
Berlin gestrandet sie kommen aus
verschiedenen afrikanischen Ländern
Professorin Katharina Larisch bringt
ihnen in ihrer Freizeit medizinische
Praxis bei denn sie alle studieren
online an ihrer ukrainischen Universität
weiter und Zahlen auch weiter
Studiengebühren
natürlich können wir sagen all diese
sollen zurück in ihre Heimatländer aber
wir haben so ein riesen Lohngefälle wenn
die jetzt zurückgehen nach Nigeria
können sie sich das Studium nicht mehr
leisten weil natürlich die die Löhne in
Nigeria minimal sind wenn wir es aber
schaffen sie hier zu vermitteln auch in
Hilfsjobs die wir so dringend brauchen
haben Sie einfach das Geld um das
Studium digital vorzusetzen sie können
Deutsch lernen sie können Praxis lernen
und dann schaffen sie es wirklich quasi
ihren Traum eben jetzt in dem Fall
Medizin zu studieren zu verwirklichen
auch Aziza moruk was Professoren
Unterrichten von der Ukraine aus sie ist
22 und kommt aus Tansania ihr Traum
Kinderärztin werden sie lebte und
studierte in saporicia bevor sie
geflohen ist
ich hatte das Gefühl dass ich alles
hinter mir lassen musste ich wusste
nicht was als nächstes passiert ich
hatte große Angst gar nicht aus dem Land
zu kommen aber man muss kämpfen und sich
anpassen der Realität ins Auge sehen
sie möchte gerne in Deutschland bleiben
doch die Voraussetzungen dafür sind für
sogenannte Drittstaaten Angehörige wie
sie kaum zu erreichen zum Beispiel ein
Studienplatz in Deutschland
ich denke das Schwerste ist dass ich mit
meinem Studium nicht weiterkomme das ist
das Schlimmste ich finde keine
Universität an der ich weiter studieren
kann die Bewerbungen wurden abgelehnt
wegen fehlender Sprachkenntnisse
Visite im Berliner Vivantes Klinikum
ein Patient für Übungszwecke ein
simulierter Bandscheibenvorfall die
Studierenden haben Glück Professor
dagmarskopp bringt ihnen Praxiswissen
bei dass ihr Online-Studium an der
ukrainischen Uni ihnen nicht vermitteln
kann
eine Radikulopathie L5 entmorgen
tomorrow morning
Operation haben sie noch eine Frage an
die questions
außerdem haben sie vor einigen Monaten
eine Anstellung im Krankenhaus bekommen
in der Sterilisation für
op-bestecktsituation sie können selbst
ihren Unterhalt verdienen und der andere
Aspekt ist dass sie natürlich in der
Ausbildung Weiterkommen denn Medizin
kann man nicht nur online lernen
kann ist für mich wie ein Lottogewinn
Arzt zu sein ist für mich nicht nur ein
Traum es ist meine Berufung
als ich nach Deutschland kam hätte ich
das nie erwartet nie gehofft diese
Chance zu bekommen in einem Krankenhaus
zu lernen und zu arbeiten
dass die Studierenden jetzt im
Krankenhaus arbeiten und lernen können
liegt auch an Katharina Larisch fast
täglich ist sie im Gespräch mit Kliniken
die Hände Ringen Personal suchen auch in
Brandenburg
[Musik]
und doch ist es schwer die Vermittlung
scheitert mitunter an fehlender
Erfahrung einzelner Behörden an
sperriger Bürokratie
die Jobangebote sind da wenn sich die
teilweise die Ausländerbehörden so
weiter so quer stellen werden sie
ausgewiesen das heißt wir haben tausende
von Medizinstudenten aus Afrika die in
abgebrochenes Medizinstudium haben
die dann auch ihrem Land nicht mehr
dienen können viele möchten ja nach dem
Studium noch eine Facharztausbildung
machen und zurückgehen um aus
Anästhesist als Gynäkologe als
Hals-Nasen-Ohren-Arzt einfach in Afrika
zu arbeiten das ist dann alles nicht
möglich eine Arbeitserlaubnis haben sie
aber der Aufenthalt ist begrenzt
eigentlich auf sechs Monate Berlin hat
diese Frist noch mal verlängert aber
auch die läuft bei den meisten am ersten
März aus der Berliner Senat arbeite an
einer Lösung
wir brauchen Fachkräfte und deshalb
glaube ich ist es auch angebracht dass
wir darüber nachdenken wie wir dann nach
den sechs Monaten auch mit den
Studierenden umgehen
wir nutzen die Rundung der Nadel ohne
Kraft dass wir das weiter schieben
Praxisunterricht an einer verletzten
Banane neben ihrem Job als Hilfskraft im
Berliner Vivantes Klinikum nehmen die
Studierenden hier auch an Kursen für
angehende Mediziner teil und kommen so
ihrem Traum ein Stück näher
ich habe Afrika verlassen um zu
studieren ein guter Arzt zu werden in
Afrika ist es nicht das Gleiche wir
haben nicht die gleichen Möglichkeiten
und Ausstattungen
ich würde gerne hier bleiben die Sprache
lernen und mein Studium beenden und hier
arbeiten
das Studium beenden und nebenbei im
Gesundheitswesen arbeiten wo
händeringend Personal gesucht wird wenn
das nicht ein Gewinn für alle wäre
man kann dann tatsächlich den die
Entwicklung